So what is Docker?
Docker is an open source tool that makes
it easier to create, distribute, and
run applications.
It does this by packaging applications
as a set of container images that
include all of the dependencies
bundled with it.
Container images can be run on any
machine where Docker is installed
which means containers or
assist admins dream come true.
Reproducable and Consistant.
Containers like processes start up and
shut down quickly.
We're talking milliseconds here.
At the same time, containers provide
the benefits of a virtual machine like
isolation between applications
running on the same machine.
This means we don't have to worry
about conflicting dependencies between
our apps.
For this course, we use Docker
to package, distribute, and
run our application.